- Well, speaking of meeting cool people...
So I heard you met Prince,
and we have this thing on this
show.
Everybody has a Prince story.
- Yeah.
I don't, but everybody else does.
(all laughs)
And, and it's,
I want to know, like,
what was your experience.
- My Prince story is that I got a meeting,
like a general meeting to
go meet with this director.
And they said, "and Prince",
and I thought like Prince
Johnson from Santa Monica or
something.
(audience laughs)
- And so--
- Oh, you didn't know
it was actually Prince
that you were seeing?
- I had no idea.
- Oh, that makes me sweat.
- So, me too.
- Yeah.
- Even now.
- And so I rescheduled the meeting twice
cause I had a bunch of stuff going on.
- You rescheduled on Prince?
- I know! (all laughs)
- So the last time they were like,
"You're either coming or you're not."
And I was like, "Okay, I'm coming."
So that I come to this
meeting at this house.
And as soon as I get on the
elevator that's in the house.
I'm like, "What is an
elevator in a house?"
The doors open and it's
crushed purple velvet.
And I'm like, "Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait."
And so I look back at the
director, I'm like, "I'm fine."
- I'm fine. (laughs)
- And then the door closes
and the emblem's right there.
And I was like, I'm flipping out.
Like I'm such a Prince fan, so--
- Everyone is.
- When I tell you--
- I would be sweating so much.
- You just figured that out
right before you met him?
- I did not know what to do with myself.
- Oh no.
- So then he comes out of
the hallway and she's like,
"Prince, Megan's here."
And I'm like, "What?"
So he comes around the hallway,
he has these little Chinese pajamas,
and he has on like these
3 inch heels. (all laughs)
And his hairs tied up, he's got
his powder and his eyeliner.
And he was like, "Would
you like something to eat?"
And I was like, "Yes, yes."
Mind you I just eaten.
(laughs)
And so we go,
we sit down and we're sitting
at the table and he's like,
"Do you want salad?" And I was
like, "I would love salad."
I hate salad.
Now, I'm better.
- I love salad though.
- Now I do.
But back then I was like, "Yes."
And then he was like, "Okay."
And then the person was like, "Well,
do you want salad, Prince?"
And he was like, "No."
I was like, "I don't want either."
And then it just sounded
like I was like copying him.
I was like, "No, but I really don't.
I don't really eat salad
that much. It's okay."
(laughs)
And then they brought out wine
and literally as the woman's
walking back in the kitchen,
Prince was like, (clears throat)
and she was like, "Oh,
I'm sorry, I forgot."
She comes back out with a bright,
bright green straw,
like a child's straw and folds
it over for him and puts it
in his red wine.
And I was just like, okay.
And I'm just watching like
everything and like the tables
long.
And he's at the head of it
and me and the director at the
other side.
And I looked down and I can
see his feet are about this far
from the ground.
I can see him kind of going like that.
(audience laughs)
And then like,
he was like making little
shapes on the table.
It was the awkwardest dinner,
and I had no idea why I was
there and what was going on.
And then by the end of it, he was like,
"I want to make this documentary
about a young Malcolm X,
and I want you to play the
character and I want to show it
to you." And I was like, "Oh, okay."
So then we watched a little
bit documentary, then I left.
And then I pulled down the
street and I called my mom.
I was like, "Mom (inaudible)."
I'm screaming.
And then I like literally
was like, "Can you hear me?"
And she was like, "What happened?
Did you get a car accident?
I can't understand you."
- Oh no!
- And I was like,
"No, I'm trying to say
that I just met Prince.
And so yeah.
Best, best day ever.
- Can I--
(audience cheering and clapping)
Can I, can I tell you that
I'm actually still back
where he asked for bright green straw?
- Yeah.
- With wine.
- Yeah, I was like, "Maybe he's
a germophobe, I don't know."
I was, I was trying to put it together.
- That's amazing.
- I would, I'm like so weird.
I wouldn't have been able to let that go.
The whole dinner I'd
have been like, "Why?"
I probably would've had to ask him.
That's why I've never met Prince.
He knew, he knew.
Don't invite that weirdo to my house.
Have you ever met Prince?
Did you ever meet him?
- No.
- Okay yeah, we don't have cool stories.
Yeah, I'm not cool either.
You know, I was like,
everyone has one, it's crazy.
- Oh, I have a Prince story,
but it doesn't involve meeting him.
- Oh wait, I want to
know the Prince story.
- Do you remember those little records?
They were like 33 and a
thirds back in the day.
- Yeah.
- So they used to give those
out at bar mitzvah parties.
Like if you won the limbo contest.
(audience laughing)
- I was 10 years old.
It was like my older,
it was my older brother's
friend's bar mitzvah.
And that was the prize
was Erotic City on 33.
Now, if you've listened to Erotic--
- What?
- not appropriate for a ten-year-old.
That's my Prince story.
(all laughs)
- I love that they gave that out.
(audience clapping)
Y'all know how to party.
Just saying.
- I was a really good limbo person.
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
Limbo and some Prince, I love it.